)
- Les entreprises Limoges,
bonjour! Ici, avec notre
superficie de plancher, on est
corrects pour pas avoir besoin
du passeport vaccinal.
- Cette quincailleee
de L'Assomption reçoit beaucoup
d'appels depuis quelques jours x
de savoir s'ils doivent
présenter un passeport
vaccinal pour entrer.
- Allô! Ça va bien?"
- Oui. Vous?
- Heureusement pour eux,
la surface de vente
de ce magasin se situe juste
par la santé publique.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS DOYON,
entrepreneur
- Je trouve ça devient extrême
isisisisisisisisisisisisisisisie
dans les hôpitaux puis tout ça,
là, on a déjà de la misère à
avoir nos matériaux, là, on mete
un petit fardeau de plus.
- C'est une mesure de plus qui
s'ajoute puis qui s'ajoute puis
qui donne s s s s s s s s s s sx
qu'ailleurs, on n'est pas pires
qu'ailleurs, on a des mesures
pas mal sévères.
- La circonscription
de François Legault est semi-
rurale. Elle regroupe
de Lanaudière, dont celle de
L'Assomption, un villatttt
l'économie repose en grande
partie sur son collège régional,
son théâtrtrtrtrès prisé et
les multiples commerce
en dépendent. C'était autrefois
le bastion péquiste de Jacques
Parizeau; c'est maintenant
- Ça prend-tu
une identification?
- M. Legault, c'est le papa
de tous les Québécois.
sososososon coeur qui parle, là.
J'aime bien M. Legault.
- On commence à être tannést t i
se passe, mais personnellement,
pour le travail de M. Legault,
comme LeLeLeLeLegault, je vais
voter pour vous!
- J'avais mon petit commerce.
J'ai dû mettre la clé danspppppp
de clientèle en esth
- Cette résidente
de L'Ass
fermeture des commerces imposée
lelelelele gouvernement Legault.
KIM BEAUREGARD, ancienne prop.ne
travaillent dans des petits
commerces, alors
est fermé, bien, l'économie
roule pas.
- nsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsnsne
votre perception du gouvernement
ou de M. Legault ?
- Oh! la, la, oui! À voir
comment, dans d'autres pays,
ils traitent la COVID, regarder.
MÉLANIE ROUSSEAU, prop.,
Café St-GabrielC'C'C'C'C'C'est .
Moi, d'habitude, j'ai un
line up. J'ai des étudiants,
j'ai des enseignan
viennent. Les bureaux sont tous
en télétravail. Tout ça faitfff.
- Quanememememememande si
elle appuie toujours son député
local, la boulangère hésite.
- J'en tiens pas rigueur persons
si quelqu'un d'autre aurait pu
faire mieux, mais ça porte
à réfléchir à
- La circonscription adjacente
à celle de François Lenenenenenn
l'électorat de la région.
LISE LAVALLÉE,
députée de Repentigny, CAQ
- Ces temps-ci, je pense que
o o o o o o o o o o o o o o o é
exemplaires, qu'ils doiventr r s
pour le 10 % qui ne répond pas,e
une exaspération qui s'installe.
- Je vous disais, la semaine
passée, qu'on voyait
- Le premier ministre Legaultrét
la lumière au bout du tunnel.- .
On souhaite naturellement
que sosososososososoit derrière
nous puis qu'ils comprennentono.
- Les électeurs de L'Assomption.
- Je sais pas; on n'a pas
les mêmes yeux, je pense,
pas le
je la vois, mais il me semble
qu'elle est bien loin encore.
Elle a l'air encore bien loi